your plan has been foiled no now  everyone will think i invented the cool  thing but i invented that shut the [ __ ]  up  now let me explain how i actually think  bad things are good wait  is that thing still recording i i like  it when people fit into their roles in  society while i say one thing in public  i actually do the opposite in private my  faith in the system has fundamentally  shattered and one more thing  is that thing recording me right now yep  and it's been recording me the whole  time uh-huh and now something comical  will occur before i am inexplicably and  immediately arrested by the police i  mean probably whoa i'm slipping on a  banana peel how dare you try to change  society for the better you little  dummy dumbass good riddance hey child's  protagonist uh-huh yeah your dog died  okay what the [ __ ]